Hey, everybody. My
name is Dr. Adam Hurst.
The lecture today is
Clinical Approaches
to Immunological Deficiencies.
Here are our session
objectives. It's
really kind of broken
up into two sections.
The first three points,
walking through, really just
understanding the difference
between a primary and
secondary immunodeficiency
and some of the causes that
could be because of a
secondary immunodeficiency.
explaining the signs and
symptoms for suspicion on
a primary immunodeficiency,
and also making sure you
understand the history
and physical exam on when
to consider a primary
immunodeficiency. The second
part is going to cover more
specific immune defects.
So we walk through the
clinical and non-clinical
features, labs, and treatment
approaches for common
variable immunodeficiency,
selective IgA deficiency,
IL-12 deficiency,
chronic mucocutaneous
candidiasis,
Chidiakagashi disease,
and chronic
granulomatous disease.
And so as you start thinking
about immunodeficiencies,
commonly it's viewed as
disorders that are in
infancy or disorders
that are diagnosed after
infancy. And this lecture
today will really just cover
ones that are going to
diagnosed after infancy.
So when you look at
immunodeficiencies,
primary or secondary,
but it's a defect in the
immune system resulting
in a weakened or a
dysregulated immune system.
It can be due to both
either a primary or a
secondary cause, usually
presenting as an unusual,
recurrent, or a prolonged
or severe infection.
With primary
immunodeficiencies, it's
really that inherent
defect in immunity,
something that
you're born with,
commonly arising from
an inborn deviation in
the genetic code and
presenting in usually an
infancy or early childhood,
but sometimes not
until early adulthood
that it could present.
Most commonly it's
a problem with B
cells, but it will
kind of cover all
the different types
that it could be.
For secondary
immunodeficiencies,
so now you're thinking
about a different cause,
so some sort of other
factor that could cause
that weakened immune system
or disregulated immune
system. And it could be
because of medications,
viral infection, HIV, measles,
if you had a protein losing
state, so nephrotic syndrome,
specific metabolic disorders,
if If you're a *********
baby, if they have acquired
asplenia, like from sickle
cell anemia or an autoimmune
disorder, can put them
at risk for having that
secondary immunodeficiency.
And now, as we start
talking primarily
on primary immunodeficiencies,
the secondary
ones can be really
because of numerous factors.
And so that's where
obtaining a patient
history is really vital
to ruling out whether
it's primary or secondary
immunodeficiency.
Now as we keep talking about
primary immunodeficiencies,
understanding there's
over 300 of those, and
so helping us kind of
figure out which infections
could be causing that cause,
or the underlying defect
puts you at highest risk
for specific infections,
but that'll help kind of
narrow your field of focus.
So with primary
immunodeficiencies, they both have
infectious and non-infectious
features and then a
primary immune efficiency can
involve defective immunity
that not only results in
an inability to defend
against infectious agents
but also produces impaired
ability to navigate the
internal environment and so you
could cause autoimmune or
auto-inflammatory conditions
and while the clinic the
infectious features are
really important also making
sure you're aware of the
non-infectious features
because it can really help
you be a presenting initial
feature of the disease.
And it can really involve
almost every organ
system. So for like
a GI, you can get
inflammatory bowel disease
or enteropathy with
dermatology, severe eczema,
ectoderma dysplasia,
abnormal skin or
hair pigmentation
from an endocrine
aspect, diabetes,
thyroid disease,
adrenal insufficiency.
You can have
lymphoproliferative disease or
hematophagocytic
lymphohistiocytosis, and so a
wide range of non
-infectious features as well.
I am a pediatrician,
and so this slide fits
perfect for kind of
helping figure out when
do you suspect a primary
immunodeficiency.
And so if you had
four or more new ear
infections within a year,
if there were two or
more serious sinus
infections within a year,
two or more pneumonias
within a year, recurrent
deep skin abscesses, and
so thinking recurrent
infections over the course
of a year. If they needed
two or more months on an
antibiotic for impact,
if they were having
failure thrive,
persistent thrush,
kind of thinking about
prolonged antibiotics,
did they have to get
IV antibiotics to clear
infections and so more
serious of an infection.
Is there a family history
of primary immunodeficiency?
And so just fun slides
to kind of think
through when should
I be suspecting this?
Is it a serious infection
at an unusual site? Is
it an unusual pathogen
that caused their illness?
Or is it an unusually
severe infection that was
from a common pathogen? So
just different presentations
of common things, but
really thinking about
when to suspect it with
frequent infections or
current infections, a poor
response to treatment,
a failure to thrive, or
those unusual infections.
And diagnosis can be really
difficult, so a thorough
medical history is
vital. It can mimic other
syndromes or diseases, and
this is why having that
continuity of care is really
important. you can see
the big picture. You're
aware of all their infections
and what antibiotics they
needed. This is where
it's hard if they see
different urgent care
providers or ER providers or
change doctors to not have
that continuity and not
put that piece together.
And so as I mentioned
important the importance of
history taking so as you
walk through it hey what's
important and you're gonna
had a great medical history
and especially with a birth
history did were there any
maternal illnesses any
exposures to toxins what was
their gestational age because
hey were they *********
and is that having them
at a risk for a secondary
immunodeficiency understanding
what their birth weight
and height was did they
have a delayed separation of
the umbilical cord because
that can be related to
like leukocyte adhesion
disorder what was their newborn
screen? Did anything come
back falsely positive or
falsely positive
or positive on it?
How is their growth
and development?
Are they tracking
percentiles? Are they
having slow growth
in any aspects?
Did they get all
their immunizations?
Did they have any
adverse effects with
it or any concern
for vaccine failures?
What medications are
they on? Are they
on any immunosuppressive
medications?
From a past medical
history standpoint,
do they have any non
-infectious disorders?
Is there any family history
of immunodeficiencies
or death of a young child
due to an infection?
From a social
aspect, are there any
environmental exposures
that could put
them at risk? So
allergens, toxins,
contaminated water
supply, do they live
on a farm, have
different animals for
different kind of
exposure to pathogens.
What's their infection
history? What age
were they? What did
they get? How severe
was it? How did they
respond to treatment?
And as we talked too about
the non-clinical features,
this is where kind of
getting a really good review
of systems can help a
lot. So what's their skin
review systems? Any specific
skin lesions or findings,
concerns, has their
vision changed, change any
bowel habits, specific
weight loss or weight gain.
From a physical exam
standpoint, having
their height and
weight, so you can
evaluate their growth
chart and trends.
From the AT&T standpoint,
do they have any
dysmorphic features? Are
they have any sinus
symptoms, so nasal
discharge, oral
pharyngeal symptoms? Do
they have ulcers,
gingivitis, oral thrush,
any lymphadenopathy? Do they
have any hepatosplenomegaly?
From the musculoskeletal,
do they show
signs for arthritis
or multiple fractures?
And the dermatologic
aspect, what's their hair
pigmentation, the thickness
of their hair, are there any
scars, warts, severe eczema?
So again, physical exam
findings that could help
guide you towards a a primary
immunodeficiency or a
secondary immunodeficiency.
And also realizing
their physical
exam may be completely normal.
And so that's where your
history can really help.
So if you get to the
process and you are now
suspecting an immunodeficiency,
what's that work
up? And it really is a step
-wise approach. Starting
with the basics and
going from there. So
you're getting a great
history and physical exam.
Starting with the
CBC, making sure
that their counts
are appropriate,
getting cultures or imaging
when it's indicated, and
as that suspicion continues
to arise, do you check
immunoglobulin levels? So your
IgG, IgA, IgM, IgE levels.
Do you get titers for
specific pathogens,
pneumococcus, your
tetanus titers?
And so starting at kind
of the basics and working
your way as your history
and as your labs guide you.
So as I mentioned a
little bit ago, there's
hundreds of primary
immunodeficiencies.
One way to think about them
and to begin to understand
them is to categorize
the immunodeficiencies by
their underlying defect.
That can help you kind of
understand how the immunodeficiency
may typically present.
So knowing the types of
infections and the organisms
that are most characteristic
with each cell type.
Now there's a lot of other
ways to categorize these,
but in some way having
an organization can help
keep it kind of straight
in your mind. So as you
look at kind of B cell
disorders, T cell disorders,
combined B and T
cell disorders,
or phagocytic disorders.
So here's a similar
chart for again kind of
categorizing them but now
breaking it down to which
infection so which agent is
causing that immunodeficiency
and so having that
awareness of the infections
associating with a T
cell dysfunction or a
phagocytic capacity and
knowing that organism can
really help guide you as
you see your patient and
figuring out what to
test for and how to treat
and so if you think about
an antibody deficiency,
so kind of a B-cell disorder,
the main are going to be
your bacterial encapsulated
organisms. So we're talking
about Streptococcus,
Haemophilus, Pseudomonas,
Staph, Neisseria.
Also can you have
enterovirus and Giardia,
so with those
antibody deficiencies.
For like a combined
immunodeficiency, you're
going to have the same
because you don't have
those antibodies, so
still having those
encapsulated organisms,
but also now having kind of
protozoal and so your
pneumocystis, toxoplasmosis,
cryptosporidium, and
non-tuberculosis.
And so having kind of
different organisms on top of
your bacterial for your
combined immunodeficiencies.
Looking at the phagocytic
disorders, so predominantly
like staph pseudomonas, but
also your fungal infections,
so candida, aspergillus
are other common ones.
And if a complement
deficiency, again,
similar to your
antibody deficiency,
but also get Neisseria
meningitis, too.
And so as you've walked
through and you're
starting to then
break down if it's a
B cell, a T cell,
combined, phagocytic,
now this can help you guide
which step to take next.
You've thought about what
pathogen is causing it, so
suspect a humoral defect.
So now if you walk through
and get in flow cytometry and
looking at specific cells,
and a lot of this is going
to be in conjunction with
immunology as you continue
to work up your patient.
And this is kind of similar
to that other slide,
just a different kind
of organization on which
tests and what organisms
you are thinking
about with suspected
primary immunodeficiencies.
So that was a quick
kind of walkthrough of
primary versus secondary
immunodeficiencies,
the history, the
physical exam, and so now
kind of getting into
more specific disorders
and kind of walking
through their defect,
infectious and non
-infectious features,
the labs, and the treatment.
And so with our B cell
disorders, so usually
there's no signs
or symptoms until
about three to four
months of age, and that's
because of the maternal
IgG protection.
antibodies are essential
in the sinopulmonary and
mucosal surface protection
and so if you don't have
those antibodies after
you've gotten to that age
now you're going to commonly
present with recurrent
otitis media sinusitis
pneumonia you could also
get osteomyelitis meningitis
sepsis but commonly
thinking more the sinus
respiratory illnesses and there's
kind of those common
pathogens that we talked
about just a moment ago
so we'll walk through two
specific disorders
here. So common variable
immunodeficiency, so CVID.
The defect is a heterogeneous
group of disorders of
impaired antibody production.
So you have phenotypically
normal B cells,
but they don't
differentiate due to an
arrest in the plasma
cell differentiation.
And so that leads to a
hypogamma globulinemia.
So you're going to have
a low IgG, low IgA,
and sometimes a low IgM.
Your B cell numbers can
be completely normal
or they could be low
but again you have
normal B cells that
aren't differentiating
so you don't get
those immunoglobulins.
And it's commonly various
genetic defects or no
specific one and it can be
autosomal dominant, autosomal
recessive or even sporadic
and commonly pretty
equal in both males and
females and usually won't
present until the second
or third decade of life.
From infectious features,
it's going to be
those sinopulmonary
infections, so strep,
haemophilus, mycoplasma.
You can get kind of
chronic GI infections or
malabsorptive symptoms
that could be due to Giardia,
Campylobacter, Salmonella.
You can sometimes even
have a septic arthritis
or a meningitis, but
those are not as common.
The non-infectious
features are commonly of
like an immune
dysregulation presentation.
So you have an autoimmune
disease. You show with
rheumatoid arthritis, a
thyroiditis, alopecia, vitiligo,
sometimes with presenting
with like a malignancy
because of an increased risk
of lymphoma, usually associated
with like EBV, or like
a granulomatous disease.
You could show some chronic
lung disease or a GI disorder.
Again, features that are
related to antibodies
and not having that
protection is going
to be your main
infectious presentation.
From a lab work standpoint,
you're going to have,
as we said, a low IgG, a
low IgA, and or a low IgM.
Showing a poor immunization
response would also
be present if you checked
titers on your vaccines.
From a treatment
standpoint, you treat with
antibiotics. You can treat
with IVIG as well, again,
replacing those
antibodies, and monitoring
super closely for non
-infectious complications.
And really the long
-term prognosis can
be pretty normal for
a life expectancy
if you only have
infectious symptoms.
The poor prognosis is
if you start showing
autoimmune or non-clinical,
non-infectious features,
worrisome of a
lymphoproliferative disorder.
And so I'm kind of
able to watch that as
your long-term management
of your patient goes.
For selective IgA
deficiency, and so this is
just an isolated absence
or a near absence of
IgA. So commonly it's
less than 5 to 10 on a lab
check. And the underlying
defect is not known.
And again, you're
having normal B cells,
but almost a complete
absence of IgA.
Clinically, it's a pretty
variable presentation,
and commonly it's
asymptomatic, and it's
also one of the
most common primary
immunodeficiencies found
in almost 1 in 500 people.
And similar to the CVID, you're
going to have presentation
with recurrent
sinopulmonary infections, so
from strep pneumo, H flu,
those are because of the low
antibodies, or from like
Giardia, the GI infections.
Non-infectious
features, whether
it's food or
respiratory allergens,
a GI disorder, having an
increased risk of an immune
disorder, but also a non
-infectious feature being an
anaphylactic reaction to
IVIG, or a blood product.
The labs, it's tricky
because you can't confirm an
IgA deficiency until they're
at least four years of
age because that's when
your IgA levels would reach
adulthood. You would have
a very lower and complete
absence of IgA with
normal IgM and IgG levels.
And if they're asymptomatic,
you really just kind of talk
about risks, educate them
on the disorder, signs and
symptoms to monitor for.
You treat the recurrent
infections and if it's really
severe you can screen them
for anti-IGA antibodies.
Though one thought with a
treatment aspect you cannot
give IVIG. Commonly IVIG
contains some IGA and
there's a potential for
an anaphylactic reaction
commonly because the patients
do have IGA antibodies.
And so just a simple a
sample case question. So a
five-year-old presenting
with watery diarrhea
stomach cramps that have
been present for several
days. She has a past
medical history of sinus
infections and multiple GI
problems with the past year
and up-to-date on vaccines
with no adverse reactions
reported. Still antigen
is positive for Giardia
and she's admitted for
IV fluids and recovery.
Once she recovered she
follows up in clinic
where her CBC and IG
panel show an IGA of
less than five with a
normal IgM and an IgG.
So now what is the
most likely diagnosis?
So a low IgA, normal
IgM, and normal
IgG. So kind of
hopefully leading you
guys towards a selective
IgA deficiency.
Because IgG and IgM weren't
completely normal,
it wouldn't be A,
B wouldn't be associated
with a female patient,
and it's not a common
presentation with
chronic granulomatous
disease, which you'll see.
So that being B cell disorders
and now kind of shift
into T cell disorders and
that can result in both a
humoral or a cellular immune
effect and both because
the T cells and the antigen
presenting cells provide
necessary signals for your
B cell differentiation and
so you're susceptible to
bacterial infections like
we talked about but also
fungal mycobacterial protozoal
infections so those
encapsulated organisms can be
a common bacteria that
you'll present with but also
pneumocystis, cryptosporidium,
candida, aspergillus.
Also, your viral
infections can often be
more severe, persistent,
or disseminated.
So kind of talking through
IL-12 receptor deficiency.
And so kind of
refresher on an IL-12.
And so IL-12 is a cytokine
that's secreted from
macrophages, neutrophils,
and dendritic cells
in response to infection
from microbacteria.
So your IL-12 gets
secreted, it binds to the IL
-12 receptor that's on
NK cells and T cells,
and that then stimulates
your interferon gamma.
Interferon gamma
activates phagocytes to
secrete TNF-alpha,
destroy those microbes.
If you're a visual
learner, you can find
some of these links
on that pathway, but
just thinking about
IL-12, it's secreted,
binds to its receptor, and that
stimulates kind of
that phagocytosis and
the microbial killing
of an infection.
Now if you don't have
the receptor or there's a
autosomal defect in either
chain of that receptor,
now you have a loss in
that signaling pathway,
which leads to recurrent
infections. And
so from either
salmonella, mycobacterium,
non-tuberculosis,
non-infectious features
aren't really common.
And so, but I think from
the standpoint of thinking
commonly in early
childhood or even sooner in
some countries that
administer the BCG vaccine,
seeing some of these
infectious features
because of the isletal
receptor deficiency.
From a lab standpoint there's
two aspects you can think
about whether it's
molecular testing. So that's
getting like a gene panel or
sequencing candidate genes.
It's commonly easier,
faster, and more reliable and
much less expensive to move
right to molecular testing.
Candidate genes can be
screened individually
in panels by whole
genome sequencing.
The other thought
in terms of testing
is you could do it
like immunologic
testing. So this is
functional testing.
It's not super useful
from the clinical
standpoint. It does
kind of show your
cytokine secretion
and the response,
but commonly more used
as like a research
testing for standardization and
how we're learning
about the pathways.
Treatment wise again
you're going to
treat with your
antibiotics and then it
can also treat with
interferon gamma.
Trying to, since you
don't have that pathway,
give what that end result
of the pathway would do.
Another T-cell disorder
being chronic microcutaneous
candidiasis. So that's a
defect in the homogenous
group of disorders characterized
by an impaired immune
response to candida.
You have defective Th17
lymphocytes or some sort of
defect in that synthesis or
signaling of IL-17. And
there's usually various gene
defects. One to commonly
be aware of is that AIRE,
so an autoimmune
regulator deficiency,
which is autosomal
recessive, or a STAT1
defect, which is
autosomal dominant.
So those are two common
ones, which we'll talk
about in a minute, but
clinical features characterized
usually by a non-invasive
but recurrent candidal
infections of the skin
and mucosal membranes.
Rarely do you get invasive
fungal disease, but it can
happen, and it doesn't
usually go invasive because
you have still an immune
response and other aspects.
Usually it presents in
the first month of life,
but can even be out as to
like the second decade,
so a wide range of when
it's going to present.
You're getting those
chronic recurrent candidal
infections, skin,
nail, mucous membranes,
oral pharyngeal candidiasis,
usually it's albicans,
but it can be other
fungal organisms as well.
From the non-infectious
features, and so this
is where remembering
some of the specific gene
defect, so with ARRE
defect getting an
autoimmune polyendocrinopathy
candidizes pectodermal
dystrophy, or APECED,
also known as APS1. So
an autoimmune polyendocrine
syndrome type 1.
That was a lot of
super long names,
but APS1 is a little
easier to correlate,
but thinking with
that AIRE defect.
And then the name
talks about what is
going on. So you have
polyendocrinopathy,
so some sort of several
endocrine areas. Commonly it's
like hypoparathyroidism
and adrenal insufficiency.
So you had, there's
your PE. You have
candidiasis, So again,
because of this, you're going
to get recurrent oral
cannibal infections
and then ectodermal dystrophy,
so a skin dystrophy.
And so kind of to
name it, if you
can remember, while it is long,
it helps kind of correlate
what could be going on
with this patient who has
a very specific defect.
Other non-infectious
features, you could
have hemolytic anemia,
aplastic immunity,
malignancy to the
mouth and esophagus.
Labs, really primarily,
the labs are just
based on your
clinical features with
genetic testing for
the underlying defect.
You would also get an
endocrine workup if you
were suspected or worried
about endocrinopathies.
Treatments, you usually
will start with a topical
antifungal, but there
is often resistance, and
so having to do some sort
of systemic treatment.
And then also addressing any
endocrine or autoimmune issues.
Another sample question,
so you've got a 4-year
-old girl presenting to
the clinic with her mother
for a recent nail infection
that has not gotten any
better with over-the-counter
creams. She has a history
of multiple infections of
her skin and mouth, usually
responding with an antimicrobial
cream, but mom can't
remember the name, and she
has a picture of her nails.
So what's the most likely cause
of this patient's symptoms?
B. So she had recurrent nail
and skin mouth infections.
And if you look at kind
of the other treatment
option or option choices,
that just doesn't
really fit with the
common infection, the
common organisms related,
and her presentation.
So moving from now
from T cell to more
like phagocytic
dysfunction disorders.
And so this is a phagocytic
impairment that can
be due to Sorry,
I had a screen glitch there.
So phagocytic
dysfunction disorders.
That's a phagocytic
impairment due to either an
inadequate neutrophil quantity
or a neutrophil function.
And so the neutrophils
being that important role in
the clearance of both
bacterial and fungal pathogens.
And so you could have normal
white blood cell counts
or normal neutrophil counts,
but if the function is
impaired, you're still
susceptible to these infections.
primary immunodeficiencies
are due to the
defective phagocytic
capacity and so you'll
get maybe deep tissue
infections, pneumonia,
severe gingivitis,
or wound healing.
Commonly it's like staph
or pseudomonal that
can be the life-threatening
illness and it's
usually less than like
20% of immunodeficiencies
are fatty acidic
dysfunction disorders.
One to talk about is
Chediakagashi syndrome.
And so this is a disorder
of the intracellular
granule formation.
It's an autosomal
recessive mutation in the
CHS1 or the LIST gene.
CHS1, so Chidiak
-Kagashi syndrome 1, or
the lysosomal trafficking
regulator gene.
But this is what's involved
with organicellular
protein trafficking. You
get abnormal fusion of
vesicles, and so now you
don't transport lysosomes.
So now these lysosomes
are enlarged, they
have storage granules,
but because you have
abnormal lysosomes, you
don't have the neutrophil
function. So now
you have impaired
bactericidal activity
and abnormal chemostasis.
And so now that your
neutrophils cannot help
kill bacteria, you're
set up for infection.
You have impaired in
case cell activity, your
melanocytes actually cannot
disperse melanosomes to
keratinocytes, so
that actually can
cause pigmentation
abnormalities. And
you also get some
platelet issues.
You get decreased
platelet-dense body, and
so you could have some
bleeding diathesis.
As we talked about a
couple of the kind of the
cells that are impacted
that leads to issues, you
can kind of correlate to
these clinical features.
So whether it's frequent
and severe infections
from both gram-positive
or gram-negative bacteria,
so we talked to Staph
aureus, Streptococcus,
or kind of where their
site is, so commonly
mucous membranes, the skin,
the respiratory tract.
The non-infectious features
are really important to
know. So these are patients
that will present with
partial oculocutaneous
albinism, so have super light
skin, silvery hair, photophobia,
sensitivity to light.
They might have those bleeding
diaphyses, so
easy bruisability,
can present with nystagmus
or peripheral neuropathies,
can show ataxia.
And this syndrome can
progress in an accelerated
phase, and so it
accelerates to like a
pancytopenia, a massive of
lymphohistiocytic infiltration
and can be pretty
deadly, unfortunately.
The primary testing
for it is a genetic
test of that CHS1
or the LICE gene.
But on a peripheral
smear, you find what that
first picture was. And so
that's that giant cytoplasmic
granules that are in
leukocytes and platelets.
You might go back really
fast and look at it.
And so there's that
giant neutrophil granules
that are common on
a peripheral smear.
You can have
neutropenia, and often
present with a
hypergamic globulinemia,
so that's due to
frequent infections.
So you have more antibodies
because they've constantly
been infected, and you
have normal functioning
V-cells, and so you have
a higher IgG, IgA levels.
You can also show
abnormal platelet
aggregation or bleeding time.
Your treatment options commonly
will be prophylactic
antibiotics.
usually broad spectrum like
trimethrobranam
sulfamethoxazole.
You get pretty
aggressive treatment
if you do show an
infection as well.
Interferon gamma can help
with your NK cell function.
You could track granulocyte
colony stimulating
factor, so that can help your
neutropenia and decrease
recurrent infections.
But the treatment of choice
is hematopoietic stem
cell transplant, and
that can help prevent the
accelerated phase. It does
not stop the neurologic
degeneration or the
oculocutaneous albinism, though.
So moving to the next one is
chronic granulomatous disease.
So chronic granulomatous
disease, the defect is
a defective thagocyte
with inability to form
respiratory bursts. So
now you can't kill those
ingested catalase-positive
bacteria or ******.
It can be either X
-linked or autosomal
recessive, and
it involves genes
responsible for the
NADPH oxidase complex.
So that complex helps
with that oxidating burst,
which is super important
for your immune system to
help phagocytes degrade
internalized pathogens.
So with chronic granulomatous
disease, there's that
decreased production of your
superoxide. That respiratory
burst isn't present, so
your microbes aren't killed.
Kind of similar to some
of these pathways of your
visual, I think whether
it's on Scholar RX or the
BRICS, there are some of
these pathways to visualize
it. But just looking at
kind of that defect without
these phagocytes and that
respiratory burst, it stops
that pathway. And so your
microbes are not filled.
Clinical features are
characterized by the
recurrent or severe bacterial
and fumble infections
from catalyst positive
or granulomas for me.
So thinking about the
organs that are barriers
to infection with chronic
granulomas disease.
going to get infections
of the skin, the GI tract,
your lungs, your lymph
nodes, and usually this
presents within the
first five years of life.
Usually these
infections are focal.
You could get
bacteremia or fungemia
if not treated
appropriately though.
Kind of what we talked
about skin, pneumonia,
lymphed adenitis,
or osteomyelitis for
presentations, and commonly
it's staph, maybe serratia,
pseudomonas, or a
catalyst-positive fungal
organism, so candida
albicans or aspergillus.
The non-infectious feature
is really important
to remember as well.
So commonly you could
get anemia of chronic
disease or growth failure,
but granulomas are
usually that could be
a presenting symptom
and occurring anywhere.
And so having, if your
patient presents with
like pulmonary obstruction,
bladder outlook
obstruction, ******
fistulas. Are there
granulomas that are
causing those problems?
From a lab workup standpoint,
you want to look at that
neutrophil function testing.
And so there's two
tests to think about.
And so you have the DHR
-123 test. And so this is
a flow cytometry test
that is sensitive and
quantitative. And so this
measures your oxidant that's
produced. So you get
increased fluorescence when
DHR is oxidized and your
pathway is activated.
So you're able to
kind of quantify
that fluorescence
and your pathway.
I think this test can
help you distinguish
between like an X-link
and autosomal forms.
Another version of the
testing is your nitro blue
tetrazolyme. I said
that right, but that's a
qualitative test. So it just
kind of shows it's either
there or not there. It's
simple, it's a rapid
determination if that
oxidase activity is present.
And it makes, if it
is present, you go
from yellow to dark
blue in normal cells,
and so that nitro
blue is activated.
You could do genetic testing.
You also see
hypergamytholombinemia, again
because of recurrent
infection, so increase
in your antibodies.
It could show elevated
ESR or CRP, anemia
of chronic disease.
Treatment options, aggressively
found just treating
those infections. So
it could be difficult
because of deep-seated
or abscesses that could
even require surgical
drainage or IV antibiotics.
You would do prophylactic
treatment depending on
kind of their presentation
in your patient,
whether that's because with
for bacterial components
or with antifungals or
even interferon gamma.
Hematopoietic stem cell
transplant is curative
and there is actually
some research being
done into specific
gene therapy as well.
And so this, these are two
pictures of the testing
ran over really quick and
so on the left you have
that DHR test. So this is
a quantitative test that
shows when you get oxidation
via the NADPH pathway.
And so you get that
increased fluorescence when
the pathway is activated.
And so the top row shows a
normal response. You have
increased fluorescence.
The row below that is
actually an X-linked
carrier. So you see increased
fluorescence but also
a stable position with
nothing that changed.
And And then you have
a row that shows a
chronic granulomatous
disease patient
that has no increase
in the fluorescence.
Then on the right,
you have the nitro
-blue tetrazolymin
test, so the MBT test.
And so you see the dark
blue in normal cells, so
that shows changes from
superoxidation. So that chemical
is going from yellow to
blue when that pathway
is activated in normal
cells. You would not see
that in patients with chronic
granulaminous disease.
And so this would be
a normal patient and
something you wouldn't
see if CDD was present. So
I just have a few
other kind of case
example questions
to walk through.
So here we have a 15
-year-old presenting with
concerns for recurrent
bacteria and ammonia.
Also has complaints
of decreased
sensation in his
lower extremity.
Physical exam reveals
decreased breath
sounds and rails in
the left lower lungs.
It's very light skin and
grayish, silver sheen hair.
What's the most likely
associated lab finding?
So I'll let you
think for a second
about his presentation,
his symptoms.
And the answer would be D.
So thinking about this patient,
so they have pneumonia,
recurrent bacterial
infections, but then skin
and hair features,
suggesting albinism, and
talked about that
decreased sensation in his
lower extremity, so
is there a neuropathy?
So common presentations
with Chidiakagashi,
which would show answer D,
so giant granules
in the granulocytes
on a peripheral blood smear.
A and B would be
testing for chronic
granulomatous disease,
which doesn't present in
this way, And option C
would be a CVID, which
again would have a
different presentation.
So question four, a 21
-year-old female with a past
medical history of autoimmune
thrombocytopenia, her current
sinusitis throughout her
childhood and adolescence,
and presenting with
follow-up after a
recent hospitalization
for pneumonia.
She had previously been
hospitalized for pneumonia.
And on a review of
systems, she endorses
chronic diarrhea.
She doesn't have
any fever, chills,
or weight loss.
X-ray on admission
showed non-caseating
granuloma in her
right and left lungs.
Labs showed decreased
IgG, IgM, and IgA.
And what's the most
likely diagnosis?
I can think for a
second, but recurrent
bacterial infections,
sinus infections,
labs showed low
IgG, IgM, and IgA.
And so I'm getting to
the answer for CDIB.
So kind of getting
to a summary,
I know I'll walk
through it quickly.
The slides are kind of
broken down into the features
and the labs and the
treatment options for each
disease pathology and going
back to remembering about
which organisms to
associate with which defect.
But in summary, immunodeficiency
disorders involve an
impaired or dysregulated
immune system and can be caused
by a variety of factors,
both primary or secondary.
Primary immunodeficiencies
are associated with
both infectious and non
-infectious features.
Infections associated
with primary
immunodeficiencies are
recurrent, severe, and
are characterized by
unusual organisms.
The specific pathogen
associated with that
underlying immune defect is
helpful to give a clue to
what's going on. You
can get E-cell disorders
that are associated with
bacterial infections on
the sinopulmonary tract,
whereas T-cell disorders
more associated with
opportunistic infections
with bacteria, fungal,
or even viral infections.
And then talk through some
phagocytic disorders that
are associated with bacterial
and fungal infections.
Here are the objectives
again. Again, kind of
broken into two parts.
The first three points
covering the presentation,
primary versus secondary
immunodeficiency and
kind of initial history,
exam, and basic workup.
And then we cover each of
those six specific primary
immunodeficiencies.
Here's some references
and the feedback.
Please reach out if you
have any questions on
the lecture or anything
else I can help you
guys with. Thanks so
much and have a good day.